Stichwort
entlastungspakete das ist schon gefallen
und da kommen wir doch gleich zum
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt nachdem beim
zweiten Entlastungspaket Rentner und
Studierende bei der
energiepreispauschale leer ausgegangen
waren und es daran doch ziemlich harsche
Kritik gab beispielsweise von
Sozialverbänden oder auch der Opposition
hier im Bundestag hat die Ampelkoalition
aus SPD grün und FDP
Anfang September ein drittes
Entlastungspaket beschlossen darin auch
eine energiepreispauschale von 300 Euro
für Senioren also rund 20 Millionen
Rentnerinnen und Rentner sollen 300 Euro
erhalten auch Pensionäre und
Versorgungsempfänger des Bundes bekommen
die 300 Euro für Landesbeamte für
ehemalige gibt es Regelungen der
entsprechenden Bundesländer also wann
bekommen die Rentner diese Pauschale die
Zahlung soll bis zum 15 Dezember
erfolgen erklärt zumindest gerade
aktuell der Sprecher der Deutschen
Rentenversicherung heute soll die
gesetzliche Grundlage dafür
geschlossen werden jetzt Rednerin die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
Kerstin Griese aus dem Bundesministerium
für Arbeit und Soziales Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit
Beginn des russischen Angriffskrieges
setzt Putin bewusst hoher Energiepreise
als Waffe ein um unsere Gesellschaft zu
spalten aber er wird damit scheitern
denn die Bundesregierung steuert mit
umfangreichen Maßnahmen und mit sehr
großen finanziellen Mitteln dagegen
niemand sagt wir können alles
ausgleichen aber es geht jetzt um
zielgerichtete Hilfen angesichts der
Tatsache dass die hohen Energiepreise
für viele Menschen und auch für
Unternehmen eine existenzielle Bedrohung
sind in der Bundesregierung
konzentrieren wir uns auf fünf Punkte
erstens wir schaffen
Versorgungssicherheit
zweitens wir senken die Energiepreise
mit der gaspreisbremse und der
strompreisbremse
drittens gezielte Wirtschaftshilfen an
den wir arbeiten viertens wir halten den
Arbeitsmarkt stabil auch mit dem
Instrument der Kurzarbeit das wird viele
Arbeitsplätze retten
und fünftens wir nehmen fast 100
Milliarden Euro in den
entlastungspaketen in die Hand um
gezielt Menschen mit mittleren und
unteren Einkommen zu helfen Sie mit den
entlastungspaketen zu unterstützen und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren mit dem heutigen Gesetz
dass wir gleich hoffentlich beschließen
werden sorgen wir in zwei Bereichen für
sehr gezielte Entlastung im September
hat der Koalitionsausschuss beschlossen
dass auch Rentnerinnen und Rentner eine
energiepreispauschale erhalten sollen
heute sind wir schon in der
abschließenden Beratung und
Beschlussfassung des Gesetzentwurfs
anderthalb Monate später das war schnell
und mit Hochdruck haben viele daran
gearbeitet ich sage Dankeschön an alle
im Bundesministerium für Arbeit und
Soziales und im Parlament die dafür
gesorgt haben dass wir das so schnell
hinkriegen
wir werden es mit diesem Gesetz schaffen
dass für rund 20 Millionen Rentnerinnen
und Rentner heute die notwendige
finanzielle Unterstützung beschlossen
werden kann alle Rentnerinnen und
Rentner werden diese Einmalzahlung von
300 Euro erhalten und sie wird noch in
diesem Jahr bis Mitte Dezember vor
Weihnachten auf den Konten der
Rentnerinnen und Rentner ankommen diese
schnelle
unkomplizierte und umfassende Umsetzung
das ist genau das was jetzt gebraucht
wird und lassen Sie mich dabei besonders
drei Punkte hervorheben
erstens alle Rentnerinnen und Rentner
sind anspruchsberechtigt die
energiepreispauschale wird bei
Altersrenten gezahlt bei Hinterbliebenen
Renten und auch bei
Erwerbsminderungsrenten
zweitens ist braucht kein Antrag die
Auszahlung erfolgt automatisch und
unbürokratisch und genau das ist ja wie
wir uns den Sozialstaat der Zukunft den
Bürger nahen Sozialstaat vorstellen
drittens auf die 300 Euro müssen keine
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge gezahlt
werden sie sind unfändbar und Sie werden
nicht angerechnet für nicht zu Kürzungen
bei einkommensabhängung Sozialleistungen
aber sie werden versteuert und das ist
auch richtig so denn das bedeutet mehr
Zielgenauigkeit wer hohe Renten und hohe
Einkommen oder sogar beides hat zahlt
dann eben auch mehr Steuern darauf
insgesamt unterstützen wir mit dieser
Maßnahme Rentnerinnen und Rentner der
allgemeinen und der knappschaftlichen
Rentenversicherung der
landwirtschaftlichen Alterskasse und
versorgungsempfängerinnen und Empfänger
des Bundes mit insgesamt 6,4 Milliarden
Euro Entlastung das ist ein großer
Schritt
und ich will an dieser Stelle auch mal
erwähnen weil wir ja viel über die
Umsetzungswege der entlastungspakete
sprechen dass wir diese
entlastungseffizient umsetzen die
Verwaltungskosten bei der Deutschen
Rentenversicherung betragen nur 0,17
Prozent der Gesamtkosten das ist auch
eine wichtige Zahl liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und
Pensionärinnen und Pensionäre sind
erfreulicherweise nicht die einzigen die
von diesem Gesetz profitieren werden und
entlastet werden dieses Gesetz bringt
auch Entlastung für Menschen mit klein
und mittleren Einkommen dafür heben wir
die Obergrenze des übergangsbereichs von
1.600 Euro auf 2000 Euro im Monat weiter
an was heißt das Beschäftigte mit
kleinen Einkommen bis 2.000 Euro werden
durch diese Änderung insgesamt um
geschätzte 1,3 Milliarden Euro jährlich
entlastet und das ohne Einbußen bei der
sozialen Sicherung
ganz konkret heißt das zum Beispiel für
einen Arbeitnehmer mit 1.000 Euro
Monatseinkommen über 50 Euro mehr in der
Tasche pro Monat und zwar dauerhaft das
ist zielgerichtete Entlastung von
kleinen und mittleren Einkommen den wäre
mit einer Steuererleichterung eben gar
nicht geholfen weil sie oft gar nicht
steuerpflichtig sind meine Damen und
Herren ich bitte Sie um Unterstützung
für dieses Gesetz wir helfen
Rentnerinnen und Rentnern besorgen dafür
dass Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
mit kleinem Einkommen mehr Geld in der
Tasche haben das ist Teil unserer
Maßnahmen um unser Land zusammenzuhalten
das ist in dieser Krise wichtig und
deshalb bitte ich um Unterstützung
vielen Dank
die Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
Kerstin Griese hier zum Auftakt dieser
Debatte ja energiepreispauschale für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und Bestandteil
des Gesetzes ist eben auch die Anhebung
der verdienstobergrenze bei sogenannten
Minijobs
Max Straubinger jetzt für die Union
Präsidentin wird die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir verabschieden ja heute die
Entlastung für den Rentnerinnen und
Rentner bei den energiepausch mit einer
energiepreispauschale und das begrüßen
wir als
cdu/csu Fraktion ausdrücklich
[Applaus]
schließlich ist es ja die
Forderung der cdu/csu die umgesetzt wird
wo
und auch möglicherweise der Linken kann
ich ja zu billigen weil von der
bisherigen Regierung weil von der
bisherigen weil von der Regierung die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner im Regen stehen
gelassen worden sind nämlich
bei der ersten Entlassung Entlastung der
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer wo
die energiepreispauschale bereits als
auch bezahlt worden ist und deshalb
begrüßen wir das ausdrücklich dass die
Regierung jetzt sind die Puschen
gekommen ist und auch die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner also mit entlastet
das ist aber auch schon ein schwieriges
Unterfangen
letztendlich weil viele Teile auch mit
dabei sind die eigentlich mit der
energiepreisgeschichte überhaupt nichts
zu tun haben nämlich dass dieses
Gesetzgebungsverfahren auch für quickt
wird mit einer arbeitsmarktpolitischen
Entscheidung nämlich der Ausweitung von
Midijobs in unserem Land hier hat ja die
Anhörung sehr eindeutig letztendlich ja
darauf reagiert und bzw auch Antworten
gegeben uni sono haben Gewerkschaften
Arbeitgeber aber gleichzeitig die
Sozialverbände hier dies abgelehnt meine
Kollegen werden darauf noch auch mit
näher eingehen und das ist schon eine
Schwierigkeit jetzt für uns als cdu/csu
dem gesamten Rentenart den gesamten
Gesetzgebungsprozess hier also auch die
Zustimmung zu leben aber ich sage auch
die Umsetzung der Entlastung bei den
Energiekosten bei den Rentnern ist auch
mit großen Mängeln hier behaftet die
Frau Staatssekretärin hat er jetzt
angeführt alle Rentnerinnen und Rentner
würden hier bedacht werden das stimmt
ebenso nicht denn natürlich sind hier
dabei wieder vergessen worden zum
Beispiel
Unfallopfer die in einem Schulweg Unfall
hier verwickelt waren und Renten haben
die bekommen keine Entlastung und es
sind auch
Opfer Gewalttaten die bekommen ebenfalls
keine Entlastung und vor allen Dingen
das wundert mich natürlich weil sich ja
die FDP als besonderer ja
Repräsentant fühlt für die
berufsständischen für die
freiberuflichen der in starker Weise in
den berufsständischen Versorgungswerken
hier ihre Alterssicherung haben und die
sind ebenfalls ausgeschlossen also heißt
Rechtsanwälte Ärzte die in dem
berufsständischen Versorgungswerken sind
die bekommen nicht die Entlastung also
der Kollege dürr hat da heute früh
ausgeführt sie unterstützen alle aber
die Freiberufler haben es dabei
vergessen jetzt also das zeigt auch also
was die FDP hiermit zustande bringt dann
ist es zusätzlich schlampig gemacht bis
gestern wusste man ja nicht in den in
den Beratungen ist es zu versteuern oder
nicht zu versteuern ich bin dankbar dass
die Frau Staatssekretärin jetzt
ausgeführt hat es ist zu versteuern denn
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Finanzausschuss haben ja gestern zu
Recht hier dagegen gestimmt nicht gegen
die
energiepreispauschale für die Renten und
Rentner sondern weil die
besteuerungsfrage nicht geklärt ist und
das ist auch eine entscheiden die Frage
der bei den versorgungsempfängen müsste
sie grundsätzlich zu versteuern sein das
ist okay aber bei den Rentnern da gilt
der Paragraph 22 nach
Einkommenssteuergesetz und da es keine
laufende Leistung ist eine
wiederkehrende wäre es nicht zu
besteuern also diese Fragen sind zu
klären und müssen auch meines Erachtens
hier nachfolgen von Finanzministerium
auch mit beantwortet werden weil sonst
ist es ein Verstoß gegen den
Gleichheitsgrundsatz etc also auch mit
der Besteuerung
und dann haben wir natürlich schon noch
eine große Baustelle nämlich wie viele
bereits von den Rentnerinnen und
Rentnern hier im Rahmen der ersten
Energiepreis Entlastung schon entlastet
worden sind ich habe bei meiner
vergangenen Rede bereits ausgeführt dass
ich als Abgeordneter bereits die 300
Euro erhalten habe
und
ich habe sie schon bekommen
ja weil ich heute einkommenssteuerzahler
bin jetzt und deshalb doch doch doch und
jetzt heute Kolleginnen und Kollegen
siebeneinhalb Millionen siebeneinhalb
Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner
zahlen zusätzlich Einkommensteuer das
sind 1,2 Millionen ausschließlich aus
Renteneinkünften die wurden auch nicht
entlastet das ist völlig laut aber 2,3
Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner haben
überwiegend Renteneinkünfte aber
Zusatzeinkünfte wie zum Beispiel eine
Minijob
und weitere 4 Millionen Rentner haben
überwiegend andere Einkünfte als
Renteneinkünfte und zwar laufender Art
aus einem Gewerbebetrieb aus einer
Landwirtschaft aus das sind aber die
Fälle aus einer Landwirtschaft aus einem
Gewerbebetrieb aus einer
Photovoltaikanlage das ist auch ein
Gewerbebetrieb die wurden Straubinger
die wurden bereits entlastet
dass die doppelt entlastet werden also
die Rentnerinnen und Rentner die
eigentlich besser gestellt sind werden
doppelt entlastet das sind einer
sozial-liberalen Straubinger ihre
Redezeit war bereits länger zu Ende
gewesen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nee hat ihn niemanden Zwischenfrage
gestellt nicht jetzt und jetzt sowieso
nicht mehr sie haben sich selbst
zwischen Frage gestellt aber das gilt
nicht als Verlängerung der Teilzeit
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat ja da muss
die Bundestagspräsidentin natürlich
drauf achten auch wenn er kaum zu
stoppen bei Max Straubinger aber jetzt
am Rednerpult Markus Kurt für die Grünen
Damen und Herren
Herr Straubinger da muss man doch jetzt
einiges noch mal klar ziehen bei
dem was sie hier gesagt haben also zum
einen haben wir hier die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner nicht im Regen stehen lassen
sondern wir machen ja jetzt etwas mit
einer gewissen Verzögerung aber
natürlich ja gut wenn sie sich daran so
hochziehen wollen wenn Ihnen das gefällt
tun sie das jetzt wo die Abschläge
steigen bekommen Rentnerinnen und
Rentner jetzt diese Pauschale sie sind
nicht vergessen worden und andere
Gruppen sind auch nicht vergessen worden
sie wissen ganz genau dass wir gestern
im Zuge der ausschussberatung im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales eine
Protokollnotiz ausdrücklich quasi
hinterlegt haben wo wir die
Bundesregierung auffordern
zu sehen bei Personen die die
energiepreispauschale noch nicht
bekommen haben beziehende von
Übergangsgeld beispielsweise da kann
aber auch nach dem
Bundesversorgungsgesetz oder
Entschädigungsrecht Unfallopfer dabei
sein wir haben die Bundesregierung
aufgefordert
nachzusehen wie man diesen Personenkreis
trotzdem in Zukunft dann in einem extra
Verfahren die energiepreispauschale
zukommen lassen kann das gehört zur
Wahrheit mit dazu und wir haben es nur
deshalb jetzt in diesem
Gesetzgebungsverfahren nicht geschafft
weil es uns wichtig war dass die
energiepreispauschale für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner schnell kommt dass sie eben
noch im Dezember da ist und nicht erst
nächstes Jahr das ist der Hintergrund
und darüber hinaus sie können mir ja
eine Zwischenfrage stellen anstatt zu
brüllen Herr Stracke und darüber hinaus
ist es so dass natürlich das habe ich
schon bei der ersten Lesung letzte Woche
hier gesagt das natürlich
Engel da sind wenn es schnell gehen muss
dass man dann
Abstriche machen muss bei der
Zielgenauigkeit und das betrifft
natürlich die von Ihnen angesprochenen
Doppelzahlungen wobei auch hier der
Korrektheit halber anzumerken ist dass
sie als Abgeordneter Herr Straubing hat
keine energiepreispauschale bekommen
haben ich habe sie als Abgeordneter auch
nicht bekommen nein sie haben sie
bekommen weil sie neben ihrer
Abgeordnetentätigkeit noch selbstständig
tätig sind so
das ist der Punkt weswegen sie jetzt
dann als Rentner noch mal eine zweite
Zahlung haben aber Abgeordnete haben die
energiepreispauschale nicht bekommen das
möchte ich hier betonen weil sonst
wieder Gerede ist von Selbstbedienung
und so weiter und dann muss man auch
noch mal sagen sie behaupten
Freiberufler hätten die
energiepreispauschale nicht bekommen
auch das stimmt nicht Freiberufler haben
wie selbstständige haben die
energiepreispauschale natürlich trotzdem
bekommen was sie wirklich meinen sind
die in Beruf was sie meinen genau sind
diejenigen die in berufsständischen
Versorgungswerken sind das sind aber
nicht Freiberufler automatisch so das
muss man differenzieren das sollten Sie
wirklich mal genauer machen anstatt hier
pauschal irgendwas rumzustreuen und ich
sage Ihnen mal
in den berufsständischen
Versorgungswerken da finden sich
Apotheker es gibt sie für Ärzte
Rechtsanwälte Steuerberater und da will
ich jetzt nicht sagen dass das
diejenigen sind die die allergrößten
Probleme mit den Energiepreisen haben
und die Versorgungswerke selbst das sind
ja quasi Rententräger den steht es auch
frei selber entsprechende Vorkehrungen
für die bei ihnen Versicherten auch
vorzunehmen also ich glaube wenn man
sich differenziert das ganze ansieht
dann bleibt von ihren Vorwürfen außer
dem dass es ein bisschen spät kommt
nicht viel übrig und ich freue mich wenn
sie nachher diesem Schritt der
Entlastung für Rentnerinnen und Rentner
dann auch zustimmen danke
ja Markus kurt war das der hier
gesprochen hat für Bündnis für 90 die
Grünen er sitzt unter anderem im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales und es
gab während seiner Rede einen Wechsel im
tagungspräsidium die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Yvonne Mack
was leitet jetzt die Bundestagssitzung
ruft die nächste Rednerin auf Ulrike
Schilke Ziesing für die afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen verehrte
Bürger es kreister der Berg und gebar
eine Maus 300 Euro sollen nun Rentner
und versorgungsbezieher bekommen endlich
möchte man sagen wir als AFD haben das
bereits mit unserem eigenen Antrag im
Mai dieses Jahres gefordert die
Bundesregierung hat sich damit nun
reichlich Zeit gelassen aber wie heißt
es doch so schön besser spät als nie
denn natürlich ist es gut wenn die
Regierung nun das nachholt was sie aus
Kostengründen oder Vergesslichkeit zuvor
und da lassen hat da mag man dann auch
über handwerkliche Schwächen des
Entwurfes hinwegsehen die zu einem
erheblichen bürokratischen Aufwand bei
der Umsetzung führen werden das nun
viele Rentner durch diese Pauschale
erstmals steuerpflichtig werden das ist
zu doppelten oder auch verspäteten
Auszahlungen kommen kann das alles wurde
bereits in der ersten Lesung mehrfach
genannt für schwerer wiegt das schon
wieder viele Menschen vergessen werden
schon wieder oder immer noch werden
bestimmte Gruppen von Entlastung
ausgenommen die aufgrund ihrer
Lebenssituation selbstverständlich auch
hätten berücksichtigt werden müssen denn
was ist mit den Landesbeamten und den
Pensionären der Versorgungswerke den
pflegenden Angehörigen den Menschen mit
Behinderung mit den Rentnern die ihre
Rente nur aus der Unfallversicherung
beziehen den Empfängern von ALG1 oder
den Empfängern von Krankengeld auch
diese Menschen müssen heizen auch diese
Menschen hätten spätestens jetzt
berücksichtigt werden müssen und bleiben
nun doch wieder außen vor wie immer zu
wenig und zu spät ist der hier
vorliegende Entwurf ein gutes Beispiel
dafür dass solche kleinteiligen
Flickenteppiche niemals genau oder
gerecht sein können sondern sie erzeugen
im Gegenteil immer wieder neue
Ungerechtigkeiten es bleibt der Eindruck
einer widerwilligen Politik nach
Kassenlage in Bewegung kommen sie erst
wenn der äußere Druck zu groß wird so
wie das hier der Fall war seitens der
Öffentlichkeit und der Opposition
nun könnte man sagen wenigstens etwas
hätten sie es doch bei belastt doch
dabei belassen stattdessen wollen sie im
selben Gesetz ausgerechnet eine weitere
Anhebung der midijob-grenze
festschreiben damit vermischen sie aus
Kalkül ein leistungsgesetz mit
ordnungspolitischen Regelungen etwas auf
das hier der eine oder andere Kollege in
der letzten Woche schon hingewiesen hat
schlimmer noch das was sie hier
vorschlagen zeigt dass nichts aber auch
gar nichts vom Erz der Lage verstanden
wurde sie wollen tatsächlich in dieser
prekären wirtschaftlichen Phase den
Sozialkassen noch mehr beitragsmittel
entziehen zu den 0,8 Milliarden Euro
durch die Anhebung auf 1600 Euro ab
Oktober soll jetzt also noch durch eine
weitere Anhebung die gleiche Summe
obendrauf gesattelt werden das heißt sie
wollen die Betriebe die vielfach um ihre
Existenz kämpfen mit neuen Ausgaben
belasten und nicht zuletzt in einer Zeit
das eklatanten Fachkräftemangel müssen
Sie neue Anreize für die Aufnahme von
Teilzeitbeschäftigungen wo sie doch
alles daran setzen müssten möglichst
viele Menschen in Vollzeitarbeit zu
bringen das kann nicht funktionieren die
Rückmeldung der Verbände auf der
Anhörung Anfang der Woche waren
jedenfalls durch die Bank verheerend
dass ich eine solche Politik langfristig
auch negativ auf die Renten auswirkt
kommt erschwerend hinzu liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn wir hier
und heute über die Zahlung einer
energiepreispauschale an Renten und
versorgungsbezieher entscheiden dann
werden wir uns als AFD diesen Teil des
gesetzesantrages nicht verschließen denn
jeder Euro der dazu dient eine die Not
von Rentnern zu lindern hilft aber wir
wissen auch wer für diese Not
verantwortlich ist mit ihrer
verantwortungslosen Energiepolitik legen
Sie die Lebensader unseres Landes und
stürzen Millionen Menschen in Arbeit in
Armut keine sogenannte Entlastung kann
das wieder aufwiegen denn das Geld dafür
zahlen nicht sie sondern wir alle als
AFD haben wir die Menschen brauchen
keine Almosen sondern eine Politik im
Interesse unseres Landes und seiner
Bürger vielen Dank
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Pascal Kober
erster Sprecher für Arbeitsmarkt und
Sozialpolitik der Liberalen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit dem
vorliegenden Gesetz werden wir
Rentnerinnen und Rentner mit der
energiepreispauschale in Höhe von 300
Euro entlasten und wir sorgen auch dafür
dass 2,8 Millionen Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer in Zukunft mehr Geld in
ihrer Tasche von ihrem Lohn behalten
werden das ist eine gute Nachricht ist
eine wichtige Nachricht in schwierigen
Zeiten und das ist gut so liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich möchte aber
auch darauf hinweisen dass es nicht wir
als Politiker sind die die unter die die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer und
die Rentnerinnen und Rentner entlasten
ganz wesentlich sind es Beiträge der
Sozialversicherung und ganz wesentlich
sind es auch Kosten die die
Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgeber die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer tragen
werden und das in der für die Wirtschaft
für Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer
schwierigen Zeiten
die steigenden Kosten durch die
Energieknappheit gestörte Lieferketten
der grassierende Fachkräftemangel an das
belastet die Arbeitgeberinnen und
Arbeitgeber schon sehr und jetzt kommt
noch diese zusätzliche Belastung und ich
möchte an dieser Stelle auch ganz
deutlich sagen es ist uns als Koalition
bewusst und wir sagen hier auch Danke
und herzlichen
Respekt und herzlichen Dank dafür dass
in diesen schwierigen Situationen die
Arbeitslosigkeit nicht tiefer sinkt ich
größer wird
das wäre jetzt natürlich kontraproduktiv
ja die Unternehmen halten ihre
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Unternehmer und
das ist ein wichtiges Signal in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten
die Energiepreise sind im August dieses
Jahres im Vergleich zum Vorjahr und 35,6
Prozent gestiegen und wir wissen alle
dass es für viele Unternehmen an die
Grenze geht und für manche auch darüber
hinaus deshalb müssen wir alles dafür
tun die Energiekosten zu senken umso
mehr begrüßen wir die Entscheidung des
Bundeskanzlers alle drei noch im Betrieb
befindlichen Atomkraftwerke bis zum
Frühjahr 2023 weiterlaufen zu lassen
wir können aber und müssen noch mehr tun
um Unternehmen nicht weiter zu belasten
und damit auch Arbeitsplätze zu sichern
die Bundesregierung hat sich mit dem
Abwehrschirm Ende September zu einem
belastungsmoratorium bekannt das heißt
keine weiteren unverhältnismäßigen
Bürokratielasten für Unternehmen denn
schon vor der Krise waren die Kosten
durch Steuern und bürokratiebelastung in
Deutschland überdurchschnittlich hoch
lieber Max Straubinger und darauf
hinzuweisen werde ich jetzt nicht
verzichten was die Steuerbelastung und
Unternehmen betrifft liegen wir mit über
30 Prozent international an der Spitze
erst Anfang der Woche haben die Normen
kontrollräte auf Bundes- und Landesebene
eine gemeinsame Erklärung verfasst darin
fordern sie die bürokratischen Belastung
für Wirtschaftsunternehmen zu senken das
hat entnommen Kontrollrat liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der cdu/csu
nicht zum ersten Mal gefordert 2019
weniger Bürokratie bessere Gesetze 2018
Deutschland weniger Bürokratie mehr
Digitalisierung bessere Gesetze 2017
Bürokratieabbau besserechtsetzung
Digitalisierung Erfolge ausbauen
Rückstand aufholen um nur einmal die
Überschriften der jeweiligen
Jahresberichte zu zitieren die deine
Politik beschreiben lieber Max
Straubinger in seinem Gutachten von 2014
kommt der Normenkontrollrat zum Ergebnis
das seit Antritt der großen Koalition
2013 für Unternehmen die Folgekosten von
Gesetzen wieder massiv gestiegen sein um
9,2 Milliarden Euro und das damals nur
in einem Jahr liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der cdu/csu wir sind gerne
bereit mit Ihnen über Wirtschaftspolitik
zu diskutieren wir kämpfen mit Ihnen
gemeinsam wir als Regierung sie als
Opposition für einen starken
Wirtschaftsstandort aber man muss auch
in der Oppositionsarbeit auch bereit
sein aus der dem Handeln der eigenen
Vergangenheit zu lernen um vielleicht in
der
oppositionellen
Motivation nicht gar zu lächerlich zu
wirken vielen Dank liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und für die Linke hat das Wort die
Kollegin Susanne ferschel bis sie
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
völlig klar dass die Linke heute der
energiepreispauschale für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentnern zustimmt
wir haben von Anfang an darauf
hingewiesen aber es bleibt es Geheimnis
der Bundesregierung warum sie ein
Vierteljahr gebraucht hat um zu kapieren
dass auch Rentnerinnen und Rentner ihre
Wohnung heizen müssen aber es scheint ja
überhaupt ein Merkmal der Ampel zu sein
sinnvolle Dinge entweder zu verzögern
oder zu vermorgen also gutes Beispiel
ist der die gaspreisdeckel ab März wo
sie dann nicht mehr nötig ist aber mit
anderen unsinnigen Dingen schnell dabei
sind also Stichwort gasumlage fakt ist
aber die Energiekreis die
energiepreispauschale reicht nicht um
über den Winter zu kommen und geht auch
an einigen Personengruppen völlig vorbei
pflegende Angehörige die weder arbeiten
noch Rente bekommen Bezieher von
Arbeitslosengeld Menschen in Werkstätten
in Menschen mit Behinderung in
Werkstätten und so weiter um nur einige
zu nennen und auch diese Menschen haben
einen Anrecht auf eine war Wohnung und
deswegen bessern Sie hier bitte nach
ein weiteres Problem an dem Gesetz ist
dass es sich um ein Niedriglohn und
Teilzeit
teilzeitförderungsgesetz handelt warum
für alle die weniger als 2000 Euro im
Monat ein Einkommen haben reduzieren
sich die Sozialabgaben das ist für die
Betroffenen zumindest augenscheinlich
erstmal gut weil sie mehr Netto vom
Brutto haben es kommt allerdings also
Staatsfrau staatssekretieren hat ja oft
das Paket von 1,3 Milliarden Euro
hingewiesen es kommt allerdings beim
einzelnen relativ wenig an es sind im
Durchschnitt 38 Euro auch davon kann man
keine
Gasrechnung bezahlen aber das Problem
ist dass die höchste Entlastung die
kleinsten Teilzeitstellen haben und
damit machen Sie diese Teilzeitstellen
unnötig attraktiv sie drängen damit
beschäftigte und das sind überwiegend
Frauen weiter in die teilzeitfalle und
das ist absolut inakzeptabel
um den Fachkräftemangel zu begegnen
sollten Sie lieber Rechte schaffen damit
beschäftigte Arbeit und Leben
vereinbaren können das würde Frauen in
Richtung Vollzeit fördern und das
könnten sie da könnten sie sich mal als
fortschrittskoalition profilieren
was sie hier im Gegenzug fabrizieren ist
nicht fortschrittlich sondern ist
gleichstellungspolitischer und
arbeitsmarktpolitischer Blödsinn und ich
ergänze sozialpolitisch unverantwortlich
dadurch dass bei den Sozialabgaben eine
Lücke entsteht Schwächen sie wieder
einmal die Sozialversicherungssysteme es
fließt weniger Geld in die rentenkranken
und Arbeitsverlust
Arbeitslosenversicherung und die in die
entstehenden Löcher dann zu stopfen
kommt dann gegebenenfalls wieder zu
Beitragserhöhungen oder
Leistungskürzungen und das kann es doch
nun wirklich nicht sein
statt immer wieder und immer wieder an
den Eckpfeilern des Sozialstaates zu
sägen wer sollten Sie endlich mal zur
Finanzierung der Krisen zur Finanzierung
der Krisenkosten die starken Schultern
heranziehen es ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe Menschen
mit niedrigen Einkommen zu entlasten
und wer in der Krise wer in der Krise
den Reibach seines Lebens gemacht hat
der kann auch seinen Teil zur
Refinanzierung abgeben wann wende nicht
jetzt ist denn die Zeit für eine
Vermögensabgabe oder eine und eine
übergewinnsteuer
darüber hinaus ist eines klar es geht in
erster Linie nicht nur um mehr Netto vom
Brutto es geht auch um mehr brutto und
ich werde sie hier an dieser Stelle
immer wieder daran erinnern an ihre
Fahrlässigkeit erinnern dass sie als
Gesetzgeber nichts gegen die tariflucht
in diesem Land Unternehmen die Löhne in
diesem Land die müssen rauf und dafür
brauchen wir eine Stärkung der
Tarifbindung und kämpferische
Gewerkschaften
und deswegen wünsche ich an der Stelle
allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen die sich
derzeit bei Tarifverhandlungen gegen den
real- und Verlust zu Wehr setzen ganz
ganz viel Erfolg vielen Dank
susanne ferschel war das die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linken ja auch sie sieht es kritisch
die Anhebung der verdienstobergrenze bei
den sogenannten Midijobs weil da durch
sagt sie die teilzeitfalle sozusagen
manifestiert würde
Tanja machalet für die SPD jetzt
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
glaube man kann trotz allem sagen heute
ist ein guter Tag für die Rentnerinnen
und Rentner und für die
versorgungsempfängerinnen und im
Versorgungsempfänger im Land weil wir
heute die energiepreispauschale
beschließen nach kurzer Beratung aber
man muss wirklich sagen dass das eine
gute Maßnahme ist die wir heute auf den
Weg bringen und
ich habe schon mal gesagt wenn es nach
mir gegangen wäre hätten wir das
durchaus auch schneller machen können
aber wenn man sich das jetzt vom
Verfahren er anschaut muss man sagen
also wir sind schnell in der Umsetzung
wir wollen dass das Geld noch im
Dezember vor Weihnachten bei den
Menschen ankommt 20 Millionen
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und
versorgungsempfängerin dies vor
Weihnachten noch beziehen werden und in
der Anhörung ist ja auch am Montag
deutlich geworden dass das funktioniert
Dank all denen und die Staatssekretärin
hat es auch schon gesagt Dank all denen
die im Ministerium daran gearbeitet
haben die jetzt daran arbeiten dass es
möglichst schnell auch bei den Menschen
ankommt
und Herr Straubinger sie haben es jetzt
heute nicht gesagt aber sie haben ja die
letzten Tage immer mal wieder von dem
sogenannten schlechten Gewissen gesetzt
geredet das ist ja ist ja netter Slogan
seien ja auch gegönnt dass der ihn
eingefallen ist ja habe ich gar kein
Problem damit aber ich glaube es wird
sich noch zeigen wer das schlechte
Gewissen beim Thema Rente haben muss
denn sie erinnern sich vielleicht daran
wir waren es die die Verbesserungen bei
den
erwerbsminderungsrentnerinnen und
Rentnern durchgesetzt haben das hat
lange mit ihnen nicht funktioniert wir
werden demnächst den Wegfall bei der
Hinzuverdienstgrenze auf der
Tagesordnung haben wir werden das
Rentenniveau stabilisieren wir werden
das Renteneintrittsalter nicht anheben
das haben wir versprochen und das halten
wir
und ja die Einmalzahlung die wir heute
beschließen die ist wichtig und richtig
in der aktuellen Situation aber es ist
noch wichtiger dass wir eine dauerhaft
gute Absicherung für die Menschen im
Alter hinbekommen und das werden wir auf
den Weg bringen dazu werden wir bald das
rentenpaket zwei auf dem Tisch haben und
ich bin gespannt wie sich die Union dann
dazu verhält ich freue mich drauf
wir haben ja jetzt am Montag ist die
Konstituierung des Bundestags ein Jahr
her und ich will auch noch mal daran
erinnern ich habe letzte Woche schon
Redezeit darauf verwandt die hat nicht
ganz gereicht aber ich möchte trotzdem
noch mal daran erinnern was wir jetzt in
diesem einen Jahr alles auf den Weg
gebracht haben noch mal aus den
entlassungspaketen 1 und 2 wir haben die
EEG-Umlage zum ersten siebten
abgeschafft davon haben auch
Rentnerinnen und Rentner profitiert wir
haben die
fernpendlerpauschale erhöht
wir haben den grundschreibetrag erhöht
wir haben den Arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag
erhöht wir haben den Mindestlohn
angehoben wir haben den vereinfachten
Bezug beim Kurzarbeitergeld auf
verlängerte übrigen auch nicht mit Ihrer
Unterstützung
ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
tun heute das was nötig ist heute
beschließen wir die
energiepreispauschale für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und die
bundespensionärin und bundespensionäre
weil es auch dazu Fragen gegeben hat die
Länder sind einige Länder sind ja auch
dabei einige Länder sind dabei auch
eigene Maßnahmen auf den Weg zu bringen
ich würde mich natürlich darüber freuen
wenn es alle täten das liegt aber
natürlich in der Länderhoheit und
gerade weil ihr auch angesprochen worden
ist dass einige Personengruppen das ist
auch in der Anhörung deutlich geworden
am Montag einige Personengruppen noch
nicht von den Einmalzahlungen
profitieren es ist natürlich immer die
Frage immer ein Spagat zwischen einfach
und schnell oder komplex und langsam wir
haben uns hier für den schnelleren Weg
entschieden deswegen haben wir jetzt
auch im Ausschuss noch mal die
Bundesregierung aufgefordert zu prüfen
welche Personengruppen tatsächlich noch
nicht von den Entlastungsmaßnahmen von
den Einmalzahlungen bisher profitiert
haben da geht es natürlich um
Übergangsgeld Empfängerinnen und
Empfänger Krankengeld Empfängerin und
Empfänger und auch die Gruppen die die
Frau ferschel eben genannt hat all das
noch mal zu prüfen und aufzuschauen wie
kann man dort noch weiter zu
Entlastungen kommen wir haben aber
bewusst gesagt wir möchten das nicht in
diesem Gesetz hier nachregulieren weil
das die Auszahlung deutlich verzögern
würde es war und es bleibt unser großes
Anliegen dass die Menschen das vor
Weihnachten auf dem Konto haben so wird
es sein und es ist auch gut so
herzlichen Dank
sagt hier Tanja maharlet für die
SPD-Fraktion sie sitzt im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und
sozialesu hat das ganze Jahr
parlamentarisch dann auch beraten worden
ist und wo es ja auch noch mal dann eine
Expertenanhörung am vergangenen Montag
gab zu diesem Gesetzentwurf und hier die
kleinen für die Union
Kollegen wir als Union begrüßen
ausdrücklich dass nun auch die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner eine
energiepauschale erhalten sollen schon
seit einem halben Jahr kritisieren wir
dass die ampelregierung 20 Millionen
Rentnerinnen und Rentner bei den
entlastungspaketen einfach vergessen hat
es ist völlig unverständlich dass gerade
Senioren die ein viel geringeres
Einkommen haben als Erwerbstätige hier
außen vorgelassen wurden und zu Recht
herrschte deshalb unter den Betroffenen
großes Entsetzen Angst und Unverständnis
in der
Expertenanhörung diese Woche im
Bundestag berichtete die Vertreterin
eines großen Sozialverbandes
eindrücklich dass sie noch nie zuvor
eine solche Menge an Zuschriften
erhalten habe und vor diesem Hintergrund
das muss ich hier auch sagen es ist noch
unverständlicher dass die ampelfraktion
das Gerät nämlich ein bisschen in
Vergessenheit zwar unseren Antrag für
die Rentner energiepauschale abgelehnt
haben nur um jetzt mit diesem
unglücklichen Gesetzentwurf zu kommen
der schon wieder Personengruppen
vergisst ja
und hier werden Personengruppen Menschen
vergessen die vor allen Dingen auch
besondere Unterstützung bedürfen
beispielsweise jene die aus der
Unfallversicherung eine Rente beziehen
oder ehemalige politische Häftlinge der
DDR die opferrenten erhalten ist es gut
dass die Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
ampelfraktionen das jetzt auch
eingesehen haben und hoffentlich wird
danach korrigiert aber liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zielgerichtetes Handeln
sieht anders aus
gleiches gilt übrigens für den zweiten
Teil der des Gesetzes der ein gänzlich
anderes Thema betrifft nämlich die
Anhebung der sogenannten midijob-grenze
auf 2000 Euro die Expertenanhörung hat
hier ein vernichtendes Urteil gefällt
und meine Vermutung ist das ist auch der
Grund warum hier kein einziger der
Rednerin und Redner der ampelfraktion
dieses Thema auch nur erwähnt hat nicht
ein einziger Experte hat sich für dieses
Vorhaben ausgesprochen auch weil damit
Niedriglohnjobs und Teilzeitarbeit auf
Kosten unserer Sozialkassen gefördert
werden
das trifft übrigens besonders Frauen
vergessen scheint das Ziel Frauen
vollwertig in Erwerbsarbeit zu
integrieren im Gegenteil mit diesen
identischen Gesetzentwurf leisten sie
einen Bärendienst für die Frauen in
diesem Land
gesamt bleibt unklar wer mit dieser
Maßnahme eigentlich entlastet werden
soll und damit steigt auch das Risiko
dass jene Hilfe bekommen die diese gar
nicht benötigen mal wieder könnte man
sagen wenn wir erinnern uns auch die
energiepauschale haben viele Menschen
bekommen die sie gar nicht brauchen
darunter gut verdienen und sogar
Minister
hinzu kommt wir befinden uns mitten in
einer sich anbahnenden Wirtschaftskrise
kleine und mittlere Betriebe wissen
nicht wie sie bei den steigenden Kosten
die Gehälter zahlen sollen ich finde ein
denkbar ungünstiger Zeitpunkt um die
Arbeitgeber zusätzlich zu belasten genau
das tun sie aber mit diesem Gesetz wir
fragen uns aber sowieso lieber Herr Heil
was unternimmt die Bundesregierung
eigentlich ganz konkret um Arbeitsplätze
in dieser schweren Krise zu sichern oder
haben sie die Unternehmer etwa auch
vergessen wo ist denn die gaspreisbremse
auf die jetzt alle warten wir halten
fest wie bereits bei den Entlastungen
für Rentnerinnen und Rentner läuft diese
selbst ernannte fortschrittskoalition
auch hier der Realität mit einem halben
Jahr Abstand hinterher wie wäre es
eigentlich wenn sie zur Abwechslung mal
ihren Koalitionsstreit vergessen und
sich daran erinnern dass warme Worte
keine Wohnung heizen vielen Dank
klein war das für die Unionsfraktion und
der Bundesarbeitsminister Hubertus Heil
sitzt hier auf der Regierungsbank
hat sich das hier angehört schon jetzt
kommt noch mal ein Redner der Koalition
das ist
der Abgeordnete Wolfgang strengmann Kuhn
von den Grünen sondern es hatte Gründe
warum die in dem damaligen
Entlastungspaket nicht dabei waren zu
den Grünen komme ich gleich aber es gab
Markus Kurt der hat das in der ersten
Rede zur ersten Lesung gesagt in seiner
Rede vor der Sommerpause ich habe es im
Juni in meiner Rede gesagt andere
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der Ampel
haben auch schon vor der Sommerpause
gesagt wir werden und wir müssen im
dritten Entlastungspaket die Rentnerin
mit berücksichtigen und das tun wir
jetzt und das ist gut so
wir sind nicht vergessen worden sondern
die waren da absichtlich nicht drin weil
wir haben weil wir haben tatsächlich ein
Problem mit der Zielgenauigkeit und da
müssen wir uns mal gegenseitig ehrlich
machen ne also in der Tat der Kollege
Straubinger hat ja selber gesagt er hat
das doppelt bekommen andere Leute haben
es gar nicht bekommen und von der Union
gab es auch an der Stelle überhaupt kein
Änderungsantrag im Ausschuss die haben
auch keine Vorschläge gemacht wie man
sensilgenauer hinkriegen könnte und da
müssen sie sich auch mal ehrlich machen
dabei
und wir haben einfach ein Problem in
Deutschland das zielgenaue Entlastungen
nicht so einfach möglich sind und das
müssen wir auch deutlich sagen aber die
Ampel arbeitet dran wir haben die
zielrunde Genauigkeit dass manche Leute
das doppelt kriegen wir haben die Ziel
Ungenauigkeit das immer noch trotz der
ganzen vielen Maßnahmen wieder gemacht
haben es Leute gibt die haben die
Leistungen nicht gekriegt aber im Jahre
Steuergesetz der Bundesfinanzminister
hat da seine Arbeit geleistet ist jetzt
endlich ein auszahlmechanismus drin mit
dem wir die gesamte Bevölkerung bedienen
können und an alle Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land Leistungen
auszahlen können und das ist was das
haben sie in 16 Jahren nie geschafft die
Ampelkoalition schafft das jetzt
und wenn wir diesen auszahlmechanismus
jetzt schon hätten dann hätten wir
diesen Flickenteppich wie manche sagen
diese Vielzahl von Maßnahmen vielleicht
gar nicht gebraucht sondern hätten
tatsächlich alle entlasten können ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt bei der
Kindergrundsicherung gehen wir weitere
wichtige Schritte wie wir Menschen
automatisch entlasten können zu dem
zweiten Punkt frau Klein hat er gesagt
er hätte noch jemand was zu gesagt da
würde ich gerne auch zur Stellung nehmen
es wird ja jetzt viel gesagt und
richtigerweise wir müssen auch an die
Menschen denken die so ein bisschen über
der Grenze von den Sozialleistungen
liegen also Leute sie 2000 Euro oder ein
bisschen weniger verdienen dass die auch
zielgenau entlastet werden wir haben wir
haben natürlich auch schon die
energiepauschale für Erwerbstätige
gekriegt die haben auch schon andere
Leistungen gekriegt aber es ist glaube
ich durchaus sinnvoll diese Gruppe noch
mal besonders anzugucken und ja auch an
dieser Stelle ist es nicht wirklich
zielgenau weil es gar nicht so sicher
ist ob die Menschen hohes Einkommen
insgesamt haben weil neues
Arbeitseinkommen ange wird es gibt
positive und negative Arbeitsmarkt
Effekte und es ist nicht so dass es Frau
ferschel und Frau klein das ist halt nur
den Effekt gibt dass Menschen ihre
Arbeitszeit reduzieren es gibt das hat
der Sachverständige Enzo Weber in der
Anhörung gesagt es gibt auch den Anreiz
dass Frauen insbesondere mit geringen
Einkommen mit geringer Stundenzahl ihrer
Arbeitszeit ausweiten auch das muss man
mitberissen also positive und negative
Effekte es gibt das Problem mit den
Sozialversicherungen was wir durchaus
sehen was wir auch problematisch sehen
aber auch an der Stelle ist die
Zielgenauigkeit schwierig und auch da
handelt die Ampel ist schon im
Koalitionsvertrag steht jetzt stand es
schon und es geht bald in den nächsten
Tagen ein Forschungsauftrag raus wo es
genau um diese Gruppe gehen wird das ist
unter der Überschrift Grenzbelastung
Transfer entzugsrate aber wenn man genau
hinguckt geht es genau um diese Gruppe
die jetzt ein bisschen über den
Grundsicherungsleistungen sind wie wir
die besser und genauer entlasten können
also was die Ampel macht wir haben sie
genau sind wir gehen aber auch an die
strukturellen Probleme dran und das ist
genau das was wir
fortschrittskoalitionen vielen Dank
ja der Punkt Schnelligkeit zu Lasten der
ziegenauigkeit der ist natürlich hier
immer wieder angesprochen worden sowohl
von Rednern der Koalition als auch der
Opposition
ein bisschen soziale Gewichtung kommt
zumindest bei der energiepreispauschale
für Rentnerinnen und Rentner noch dazu
da man die Pauschale durchaus versteuern
muss wenn man eben steuerpflichtig ist
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen angesichts
dieses Betrags lohnt es sich mal
innezuhalten in dieser Debatte das ist
die Rechnung an den Steuerzahler für
ihre komplett verfehlte Politik meine
Damen und Herren
es geht im Kern um eine Einmalzahlung
für die Rentnerinnen und Rentner in
Deutschland damit sie überhaupt über den
Winter kommen wir haben das vor einigen
Monaten beantragt 300 Euro pro Rentner
das gibt dann mal die ungefähr 20
Millionen Rentner eben diese 6,4
Milliarden Euro aber wir dürfen bei
dieser ganzen Maßnahme niemals vergessen
sie haben dieses Land in eine Lage
geführt wo unsere Rentnerinnen und
Rentner gar nicht mehr wissen wie sie
über den Winter kommen sollen und unsere
Kinder und Kindeskinder sollen diese
Schulden einmal abbezahlen weil sie
keine vernünftige Politik im Hier und
Heute machen
meine Damen und Herren warum befinden
sich denn die Rentnerinnen und Rentner
in einer solchen schlechten Situation
weil sie jahrzehntelang die Regierungen
die Rentenversicherung nicht
stabilisiert haben weil sie
jahrzehntelang keine Politik gemacht
haben die auf Familien und Kinder setzt
die demografische Zukunft unseres
rettensystems weil sie unsere
Energiepolitik und auch Sie von der
Union durch ideologisiert haben nicht
alle Energieformen und Energieträger
nutzen die wir haben sondern ideologisch
gewisse Dinge ausschreiten und das auch
noch mit einer völlig irren Außenpolitik
verbinden meine Damen und Herren Protein
führt einen grausamen Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine ja aber sie rühmen sich
gewisser Sanktionen und schlagen sein
Angebot von Gas aus und das führt dazu
dass Sie unsere Wirtschaft belasten
unsere Menschen in die Armut schicken
und den Putin ihren Gegner auch noch
reicher machen meine Damen und Herren
denn der profitiert von den gestiegenen
Gaspreisen und verdient sich damit eine
goldene Nase meine Damen und Herren
wer sein Wohlstand vernichtet wer seine
Wirtschaft abbaut und gleichzeitig auch
noch seinen Gegner stärkt der versagt
gleich dreifach das ist das
dreifachversagen dieser Dreier Koalition
meine Damen und Herren und deswegen
trage ich Ihnen auf ändern Sie sofort
diese Politik stabilisieren sie unseren
Energiemarkt sorgen Sie dafür dass die
Energiepreise sinken und zwar natürlich
und nicht durch sozialistische
Umverteilungspolitik die natürlich ihre
Idee das soziale ökologischen
Transformation ganz nahe kommt sie
wollen ja die Gesellschaft verändern sie
wollen ja die Wirtschaft zu einem Wandel
zwingen aber das funktioniert nicht am
Ende werden keine grüne Wirtschaft und
keine grünen Landschaften stehen sondern
Verdruss Armut und bittere Abhängigkeit
meine Damen und Herren diese ökologische
Transformation ist ein Irrweg aus der
Antike gibt es noch das Sprichwort
pekunia non OLED geld stinkt nicht ich
möchte hinzufügen Gas um OLED Gas stinkt
nicht nehmen Sie das Gas sichern sie die
wirtschaftsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
meine Damen und Herren woms macht's wenn
man gegen die Wand fährt und das kann
ich das Ziel sein lassen Sie uns lieber
den Weg zur wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand
und Frieden finden danke
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Anja Schulz
[Applaus]
kleine Reminder an die Kollegen rechts
von mir Putin hat den Gast haben
zugedreht und nicht wir
sehr geehrte Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren wenn sich Umstände
ändern müssen Dinge auch neu bewertet
werden und unsere Politik wäre keine
gute Politik wenn sie nicht auch
anpassungsfähig wäre die Ursprungsidee
für die Zahlung einer
energiepreispauschal war es
berufsbedingte mehr Ausgaben abzufedern
immerhin waren die Spritpreise vor
einigen Monaten noch eine der höchsten
Kostenpunkte für die Menschen
Rentnerinnen und Rentner waren bei allen
Maßnahmen der drei entlastungspakete in
Höhe von knapp 90 Milliarden ganz klar
auch Teil der Zielgruppe beim 9
euro-ticket war der Abschaffung der
EEG-Umlage bei der Erhöhung des
steuerlichen Grundfreibetrags oder beim
Heizkostenzuschuss für
wohngeld-empfänger mittlerweile sind
allerdings nicht nur mehr berufsbedingte
Ausgaben schwer zu bewältigen sondern
die allgemeinen Energiekosten die
Heizkosten für ein durchschnittliches
Einfamilienhaus sind enorm gestiegen und
in Teilen und zumutbar geworden mehr als
die Hälfte der Senioren in Deutschland
besitzen allerdings das Haus oder die
Wohnung in dem sie leben
das ist sehr erfreulich denn
Wohneigentum ist eine sehr effektive
Altersvorsorge Studien zufolge lassen
sich hierdurch knapp 35 Prozent einer
durchschnittlichen gesetzlichen Rente
einsparen weil eben keine Mietkosten
gezahlt werden müssen
das ist vorbildliche Altersvorsorge
diese darf den Menschen allerdings jetzt
nicht zur Last werden weil sie Eigentum
nicht mehr heizen können
daher ist die Auszahlung der
energiepreispauschale zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt an die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner so sinnvoll wie auch nötig die
energiepreispauschale ist eine effektive
Maßnahme um die nächsten
Abschlagszahlungen besser verdauen zu
können auf die Länge des Winters hin
gesehen reicht es aber wahrscheinlich
nicht aus jedenfalls dann nicht wenn wir
das Angebot für Energie nicht
signifikant ausbauen
daher arbeitet die Bundesregierung mit
Hochdruck daran diese Angebotsseite
deutlich zu verbessern normalerweise
kennen wir es in Deutschland nicht das
Infrastrukturprojekte innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit umgesetzt werden die
schnelle Genehmigung der lng-terminals
hat in der Krise aber gezeigt was
möglich ist die Gas und die
strompreisbremse sind in Arbeit und
höheren Netzentgelte werden bereits
verhindert die Bürger werden beim
CO2-Preis entlastet und die Umsatzsteuer
auf dem Gasverbrauch wurde bereits
gesenkt
im Dezember soll die Abschlagszahlung
der Gasrechnung vom Bund übernommen
werden seit dieser Woche wissen wir
außerdem dass die drei verbleibenden
Kernkraftwerke noch mindestens bis April
2023 weiterlaufen werden damit
stabilisieren wir das Stromangebot und
die Preise können sinken dadurch machen
wir private Haushalte und Unternehmen
wieder unabhängiger von staatlicher
Hilfe und genau wie bei allen anderen
auch soll die energiepreispauschale auch
für Rentnerinnen und Rentner mit
Einkommenssteuer belegt werden das
betrifft allerdings nur einen ganz
kleinen Teil der Rentnerinnen und
Rentnern nämlich jene die über sehr hohe
Renten verfügen zwei Drittel der
Rentnerinnen und Rentnern zahlt kein
Einkommensteuer und das liegt nicht
daran wie ihr von einigen behauptet wird
dass es Einkommen der Mehrheit der
Rentnerinnen und Rentner zu gering ist
sondern an unseren nachgelagerten
Besteuerung wer beispielsweise 2005 in
den Ruhestand ging der muss lediglich
die Hälfte seiner Renteneinkünfte im
Alter versteuern und daraus ergibt sich
dass die meisten Rentner nämlich keine
Steuern zahlen müssen das ist daher
unsachliche von der Steuerbefreiung zu
reden und gleichzeitig so zu tun als
wären alle Rentnerinnen und Rentner in
diesem Land von Armut betroffen die
Rentner die die energiepreispauschale
versteuern müssen erhalten nämlich in
der Konsequenz auch eine sehr solide
Rente die Mehrheit wird die 300 Euro
allerdings brutto wie netto bekommen
unsere Politik in der in der Krise soll
also mittelfristig für die Erhöhung des
Angebots sorgen und leistet kurzfristig
Abhilfe bei den enorm gestiegenen Kosten
Anja Schulz war das von der FDP ja zwei
Drittel der Rentner zahlt keine
Einkommenssteuer vor allem zahlen die
Rentnerinnen keine Einkommensteuer die
monatlich weniger als 1000 Euro haben in
Deutschland hatten 2021 rund 4,9
Millionen Rentnerinnen und monatlich
eben weniger als 1000 € Nettoeinkommen
zur Verfügung sagt das Statistische
Bundesamt
kritisiert für ihre unlogische
Verquickung von Krisen und
Ordnungspolitik und dafür dass sie
versucht unseren Sozialstaat quasi
unbemerkt umzubauen und was soll ich
sagen am Montag haben wir ausnahmslos
alle Expertinnen und Experten der
Anhörung zugestimmt die
energiepreispauschale kommt zu spät und
sie erreicht nicht alle Menschen in
diesem Land außerdem schadet die
Anhebung der midijob-grenze den
Sozialversicherungen und dem
Arbeitsmarkt insgesamt
fangen wir mit der energiepreispauschale
an das Fazit der Experten die später
Erkenntnis der Ampel das auch
Rentnerinnen und Rentner dieses Geld gut
gebrauchen können hat dem Ansehen der
Politik in diesem Land stark geschadet
ihnen ist zuerst cool vom Sozialverband
VdK schildert dass der VdK noch nie so
viele E-Mails Anrufe und Briefe bekommen
hat wie zu diesem Gesetz Zitat das war
so viel Wut Unverständnis aber auch ganz
viele Enttäuschung das haben sie auch
gemerkt das haben die Regierungsparteien
vor allen Dingen bei der NRW-Wahl
gemerkt und auch Michaela engelmeyer vom
Sozialverband SoVD ist der Meinung die
später Einbeziehung der Rentnerin hat
einiges an politischer Glaubwürdigkeit
gekostet dieser Meinung bin ich auch
und jetzt kommt die Pauschale wo bleibt
die Frage ob denn wenigstens jetzt alle
Rentnerinnen erreicht werden und die
Antwort lautet leider nein Julia Köhler
vom Bundesverband triabilitation fasste
so zusammen Zitat tatsächlich sehen wir
eine große Personengruppe bisher noch
völlig unberücksichtigt nämlich
Schwerbehinderte chronisch kranke
pflegebedürftige die zu Hause gepflegt
werden und ich ergänze noch auch nicht
berücksichtigt sind etwa Opfer von Krieg
und Straftaten Impfschäden politische
Häftlinge der DDR und Unfallopfer die
aufgrund von Verletzungen nie in die
Rentenkasse einzahlen konnten oder die
in Versorgungswerken versicherten
Personen diese Menschen erneut zu
vergessen ist schäbig Liebe SPD
Grund zum zweiten Teil des Gesetzes der
Anhebung der midijob-grenze der DGB
sieht darin Zitat eine sozialpolitisch
fehlgeleitete Lösung die Deutsche
Rentenversicherung stellt fest Zitat
durch die angedachte Ausweitung wird der
im Äquivalenzprinzip vorausgesetzte
Zusammenhang zwischen Vorleistungen in
Form von Beiträgen und Leistungen in
Form von Renten zu Lasten der
Versicherungsgemeinschaft weiter
geschwächt und Professor Enzo Weber vom
Institut für Arbeitsmarkt und
berufsforschung kritisiert dass man
verteilungs- und entlastungspolitik
normalerweise nicht über
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge macht weil
das nicht zielgenau ist er befürchtet
dass davon auch relativ wohlhabende
Menschen von guten bis sehr guten
Einkommen aus anderen Quellen
profitieren
und ich kann das durchaus nachvollziehen
dass sie von der SPD und von den Grünen
in ihrer dreier-koalition auch mal mit
der FDP und Ihrem WLAN Klientel etwas
Gutes tun wollen da mag es naheliegend
bloß nicht zu viel für die Menschen im
unteren Einkommensbereich zu machen sie
sollten mit Ihrem Ampel Gehampel aber
nicht ihre Wurzeln vergessen Diebe SPD
der
Handelsverband HDI kritisiert dass sie
unter dem Deckmantel der akuten
Krisenlage eine grundsätzliche
politische Agenda umsetzen und die
paritätische Verteilung der Beiträge
verändern BDA und Deutsche
Rentenversicherung kritisieren ihre
teilzeitprivilegierung seien Sie doch
bitte ehrlich zu sich selbst und sehen
Sie ein ihr Entwurf schadet den
Unternehmen und das wo viele von ihnen
wegen Pandemie und Energiepreis
Explosion ohnehin kurz vor der Pleite
stehen und was noch dazu kommt sie
verschärfen den Fach und
Arbeitskräftemangel indem sie
Teilzeitbeschäftigung ausbauen obwohl
wir in Deutschland gerade mehr
vollzeitnahe Jobs oder besser
Vollzeitbeschäftigung brauchen
wenn sie es in ihrer Ampelkoalition
schon nicht schaffen nach außen geeint
aufzutreten so tun dies wenigstens ihre
Kritiker bei diesem Gesetz wäre die
Anhörung eine Zeugniskonferenz würde
ihnen jetzt einstimmig mitgeteilt sie
haben das Klassenziel leider nicht
erreicht
und das Stefan Hacke für die
CDU-Fraktion hat er gesprochen und jetzt
hören wir für die Sozialdemokraten
Annika Klose sie ist wirklich im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen verehrte
zuschauer:innen das war ja bisher eine
recht technische Debatte die irgendwie
dem Thema Rente mal wieder so ein
bisschen alle Ehre macht ich möchte eher
beleuchten um über wen und was wir hier
eigentlich genau sprechen
altersarmut ist für mich nämlich kein
abstrakter Begriff schon als Kind hat
meine Großmutter mich regelmäßig zu den
Senior in Cafés der avatar-wohlfahrt bei
uns damals in der Kleinstadt mitgenommen
was ist es gab klingt vielleicht erstmal
nicht nach etwas Besonderem Gesellschaft
Unterhaltung eine günstige Tasse Kaffee
oder ein Stück Kuchen was für die
meisten Menschen alltäglich sein mag was
für viele Menschen dort nicht denn wer
am Rande der Armutsgrenze lebt muss oft
auf genau diese alltäglichen
Kleinigkeiten verzichten und zwar nicht
nur einmal sondern dauernd jeder Cent
wird zweimal umgedreht und die Tasse
Kaffee beim Bäcker ist oft eben nicht
mehr drin und da Gesellschaft oft mit
Konsum zusammenhängt führt Armut eben
auch oft zur Einsamkeit
gerade in Zeiten wie diesen mit extrem
steigenden Preisen denke ich oft an die
Seniorinnen bei der AWO zurück und ich
bekomme eben wo ebenso wie die meisten
Kollegen hier vermutlich auch viele
Zuschriften aus meinem Wahlkreis von
älteren Menschen die derzeit große
Probleme haben ihren Alltag zu meistern
die massiv steigenden Preise für
Lebensmittel und Energie stellen Sie vor
riesen Herausforderungen und auch die
fünf beziehungsweise sechs Prozent
Rentensteigerung aus diesem Jahr können
diese massiven Preissteigerungen eben
nicht auffangen sicherlich haben viele
von diesen Menschen auch eigentlich
Anspruch auf Unterstützungsleistungen
unseres Sozialstaats wer geringe Renten
hat kann beispielsweise Wohngeld oder
Sozialgeld beantragen gerade die
Berechtigung beim Wohngeld werden wir
zum ersten ersten 2023 auch nochmal
deutlich ausweiten
aber ich weiß auch dass ich gerade bei
älteren Menschen in unserer Gesellschaft
auf großer Hemmungen gibt
Sozialleistungen Anspruch zu nehmen die
sogenannte verdeckte Armut in diesem
Land ist hoch und auch wenn wir dieses
Problem natürlich grundsätzlich anpacken
müssen und wollen indem wir
Sozialleistungen entbürokratisieren
einfacher zugänglich machen und darüber
aufklären so müssen wir gerade jetzt in
dieser akuten Krise reagieren und
Menschen kurzfristig entlasten daher bin
ich sehr froh dass wir mit diesem Gesetz
nun auch eine energiepreispauschale in
Höhe von 300 Euro an alle Rentnerinnen
und Rentner auf den Weg bringen die
durch die Rentenversicherung automatisch
ausgezahlt wird das ist ein wichtiger
und auch längst überfälliger Schritt
außerdem schaffen wir auch Entlastung
für alle Menschen mit geringen Löhnen
indem wir den sogenannten
Übergangsbereich ausbauen was bedeutet
das bereits zum ersten Oktober in diesem
Jahr haben wir den Übergangsbereich neu
geregelt wenn ich in einem Minijob
arbeitet also mehr als 520 Euro verdient
aber normalerweise weniger als 1.600
Euro verdient zahlt nicht den vollen
Beitragssatz zur Sozialversicherung
sondern der Beitrag der Arbeitgeber
Arbeitnehmer steigt erst langsam an
während der der Arbeitgeber zunächst
während die Arbeitgeber zunächst ein
größeren Beitrag zahlen und das dann
eben Stück für Stück abstillst aktuell
trifft sich das Ganze dann fifty-fifty
bei 1600 Euro das packen wir mit diesem
Gesetz noch einmal an und erweitern die
Regelung auf 2000 Euro das bedeutet wer
zwischen 1.600 und 2000 Euro monatlich
verdient kann also zukünftig netto mehr
von seinem Einkommen behalten das
schafft konkrete Entlastung für Menschen
die es dringend nötig haben und daher
ist es der absolut richtige Schritt
aber klar ist eben auch dass diese
aktuellen Probleme mit diesen Entlastung
alleine und noch nicht gelöst sind die
massiv steigenden Energiepreise treiben
die Lebenshaltungskosten in die Höhe und
die müssen dringend gedeckelt werden und
daran arbeitet dieser Bundesregierung ja
auch wirklich mit Hochdruck wir stellen
200 Milliarden Euro bereit um einen
energiepreisschutzschirm zu sparen der
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger sowie die
Unternehmen in diesem Land vor der Krise
absichert die Expertin Kommission für
die gaspreisbremse hat Vorschläge
vorgelegt um in konkret die für konkrete
Entlastung sorgen werden vorgeschlagen
ist die komplette Übernahme der
Gasrechnung für den Monat Dezember sowie
eine Deckelung mit einer gaspreisbremse
ab 12 Cent ab März wir werden daran
arbeiten dass diese Vorschläge umgesetzt
werden und vor allem auch sozial gerecht
ausgestaltet werden damit die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wirklich sicher
über diesen Winter kommen auf EU-Ebene
wurde zudem beim Energieministerin
Treffen ein Beschluss zur Umsetzung der
strompreisbremse geschafft außerdem
werden übergewinne abgeschöpft und in
Deutschland wurden alle Vorbereitungen
getroffen damit diese Beschlüsse auch
wirklich möglichst zügig in die Tat
umgesetzt werden können sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren wir arbeiten mit
Hochdruck daran die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land von den steigenden
Preisen zu entlasten dieses vorliegende
Gesetz ist ein sehr wichtiger Schritt
auf diesem Weg und hat die Zustimmung
dieses Hauses wirklich verdient vielen
Dank
ja und abgestimmt wird über diese
Gesetzentwurf dann am Ende dieser
Debatte aber drei Rednerinnen und Redner
haben wir noch und jetzt als nächstes am
Rednerpult Mareike Lotte Wulff für die
Unionsfraktion
ja liebe Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die
energiepreispauschale die wurde ja
damals als vorübergehende Sofortmaßnahme
in einer Nachtsitzung beschlossen und
hat damals finde ich sehr viel
Irritationen ausgelöst und zwar einmal
bei denen die sie bekommen und die sie
auch dringend brauchen und die sich
gefragt haben was kommt eigentlich
danach und bei denen die sie nicht
bekommen und sich gefragt haben
und diese gering brauchen Entschuldigung
vor allem die Rentnerinnen und Rentner
ich glaube auf kein Thema wurden wir
Abgeordneten und ich glaube das gilt für
alle Abgeordneten hier im Haus so häufig
angesprochen und warum war das so weil
am Ende ging es nicht nur um 300 Euro
sondern es ging um die Frage wem hilft
der Staat eigentlich in dieser schweren
Lage und wem nicht und deshalb begrüßen
wir dass sie sich jetzt dazu
durchgerungen haben die 300 Euro nun
endlich auch an die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner auszuzahlen wir haben es seit
April gefordert und wir begrüßen es dass
sie gemerkt haben wenn man in einer
Nachtsitzung zu einer Gießkanne greift
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Ampel dann sollte man auch die Gießkanne
erwischen die tatsächlich groß genug für
alle ist
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren als
Sofortmaßnahme ist das Gießkannenprinzip
durchaus auch mal gerechtfertigt aber
mittlerweile wäre es tatsächlich auch
Zeit für eine kluge Strukturpolitik und
da muss ich sagen dass ich manchmal
irritiert bin dass sie diese
ausschließlich in der Ausweitung von
Sozialleistungen sehen und dafür auch
sehr aktiv werden wie zum Beispiel
dieser Paus die sagte oder noch mal
aufforderte es lohnt sich nun wirklich
zu schauen ob man auch
wohngeldberechtigt ist das ist ja an
sich auch gut dass es das Wohngeld gibt
aber wissen Sie ich wir sehen nämlich
manchmal nach den Zeiten zurück in denen
sich Ministerinnen gelobt haben für
Dinge wie eine wachsende Zahl von
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
Arbeitsplätzen die Halbierung der
Arbeitslosigkeit eine Verdopplung der
Ausgaben von Bildung und Forschung eine
Übererfüllung international vereinbarte
Klimaziele und steigen Löhne und ja auch
einen ausgeglichenen Haushalt so wie es
in den letzten 16 Jahren der Fall war
und diese
lähmende Mentalität die kommt jetzt auch
neuerdings in der Arbeitsmarktpolitik
von Herrn Heil zum Ausdruck zum zweiten
Mal erhöhen Sie nun die midijob-grenze
nunmehr auf 2.000 Euro und in
Kombination mit dem erhöhten Mindestlohn
schaffen sie faktisch eine
Privilegierung von
teilzeitarbeitsverhältnissen und es muss
man sich jetzt mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen weil sie erst letzte
Woche Herr Heil ihre fachkräftestrategie
vorgestellt haben und ich frage mich
jetzt wie glaubwürdig ist das eigentlich
noch dass sie versprochen haben dass sie
die teilzeitfalle für Frauen bekämpfen
wollen dass sie den Arbeitskräftemangel
in diesem Land bekämpfen wollen sie
schaffen Anreize Stundenzahl zu
reduzieren und das bei einer Höchstzahl
an offenen Stellen in diesem Land und zu
Lasten unser sozialen
Sicherungssysteme meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren diese
Arbeitsmarktpolitik kann wenn überhaupt
alle höchstens eine Übergangsregelung
sein ich persönlich finde sie unsinnig
und aus frauenpolitischer Sicht lieber
Hubertus Heil ist sie einfach nur
enttäuschend vielen Dank
Mareike Lotte Wulf für die
Unionsfraktion hier in Richtung des
bundesarbeitsministers
Hubertus Heil
die nächste Rednerin Linda Heitmann
Gottes sein für die Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen der
demokratischen Fraktionen nachdem wir
zur Entlastung von allgemeiner Inflation
und der gestiegenen Energiepreise jetzt
bereits für ArbeitnehmerInnen und für
Studentinnen Einmalzahlungen beschlossen
haben tun wir das jetzt heute hier auch
für rund 19 Millionen Rentnerinnen und
Rentner ich finde das ist ein guter
Schritt und
und dass dieser Vorgang erst jetzt kommt
und deshalb stehe ich hier auch als
verbraucherschutzpolitische
Berichterstatterin meiner Fraktion das
gibt uns auch die Möglichkeit manche
Dinge eben auch etwas klüger zu machen
als im ersten Entlastungspaket ganz
konkret haben wir in diesem Gesetz jetzt
nämlich von vornherein verankert das
Einmalzahlungen bei Menschen die
überschuldet sind nicht gepfändet werden
können und ich finde das ist ein guter
und wichtiger Schritt
denn
in einer Zeit in der wir die
Schuldnerberatungen gezielt stärken weil
diese sich vor Anfragen kaum noch retten
können und in einer Zeit in der
überschuldete Menschen Angst haben dass
ihnen die Energie abgestellt wird und
dass sie möglicherweise Ihre Wohnung
verlieren könnten gerade in dieser Zeit
ist es wichtig aktiv und gezielt zu
verhindern dass Einmalzahlungen wie
diese gepfändet werden und dass Menschen
ihre Rechnungen dann erst recht nicht
mehr bezahlen können
ich bin überzeugt dass diese Verankerung
im Gesetz zwar nur ein kleiner Baustein
ist aber gerade für die vielen
Betroffenen ist es ein wichtiger um der
Verschuldung entgegenzuwirken und auch
für uns als Ampel ist es einer von
mehreren Bausteinen wir arbeiten in
dieser Regierung gezielt daran dass
Menschen sich in diesem Land weniger
Verschulden wir drehen an verschiedenen
Schrauben wieder Stärkung der
Schuldnerberatung und wir werden uns
auch angucken ob es vielleicht Sinn
macht die Pfändungsgrenzen insgesamt
anzuheben
der Verbraucherschutz für den ich hier
heute spreche das ist eine
Querschnittsaufgabe und gerade im
finanziellen Verbraucherschutz haben wir
noch einige Vorhaben im
Koalitionsvertrag den wir uns widmen
werden deshalb will ich mich als
verbraucherschutzpolitikerin auch weiter
in die Gesetzesvorhaben aller Ressorts
einmischen wenn wir dazu zu besserem
Verbraucherschutz kommen wie wir es
konkret in diesem Gesetz hier auch
geschafft haben vielen Dank
ja der Verbraucherschutz natürlich eine
weitere Aspekt der hier in diesen
Gesetzentwurf in auch diese Thematik mit
hineinspielen letzte Rednerin jetzt zu
diesem Tagesordnungspunkt bevor dann
über den Gesetzentwurf abgestimmt wird
ist jetzt für die SPD Isabel Mackensen
Geist
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren in unseren
unterstützungspaketen haben wir bereits
viele Menschen adressiert zurecht wurde
kritisiert dass wir die Studierenden und
Rentnerinnen nicht explizit bedacht
haben das wollen wir diese Woche nach
wir reden jetzt gerade über die 300 Euro
Energiepreis pauschale und ich bin
meiner Fraktion unendlich dankbar dass
ich einen ganz neuen Aspekt eine ganz
neue Gruppe mit einbringen kann als
Mitglied des Ausschuss für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft möchte ich mich den
Rentnerinnen und Rentnern aus der
Landwirtschaft speziell widmen und ich
freue mich hier auch besonders dass wir
als Ampel zusammen mit den Ministern
Hubertus Heil und Cem Özdemir eben im
parlamentarischen Verfahren auch
erreicht haben dass jetzt auch noch die
Versicherten der Sozialversicherung für
Landwirtschaft Forsten und Gartenbau
diese Pauschale erhalten
damit leben wir auch für die Landwirtin
heute die Grundlage dass sie bis zum 15
Dezember die energiepreispauschale
automatisch ausgezahlt bekommen es halt
handelt sich bei der Alterssicherung für
Landwirt um eine Teilsicherung die seit
dem Jahr 1957 besteht und wir
unterstützen Herr Straubinger sie können
zuhören vielleicht lernen sie noch was
wir unterstützen diese Alterssicherung
sie haben ja jetzt da nichts dazu gesagt
deshalb bleibt es jetzt von mir hier da
noch mal drauf einzugehen und das ist
eine wichtige eine wichtige Sicherung
mit 3,9 Milliarden unterstützen wir
nämlich die Alterssicherung der
Landwirte also das mehr als die Hälfte
des Haushalts für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft die LandwirtInnen das ein
wichtiger Beitrag für die Wertschätzung
gegenüber den Landwirtinnen und vor
allem ihrer Lebensleistung die sie
bereits erbracht haben aber auch das
wissen wir in der Rente immer noch für
uns alle und unser Land erbringen aber
wir unterstützen die Landwirte auch noch
an anderer Stelle ich komme der
Vorderpfalz bei uns spielt nicht nur der
Weinbau sondern auch der Obst und
Gemüsebau eine große Rolle das pflanzen
pflegen ernten weiterverarbeiten und
Herstellen von Lebensmitteln ist für
unsere Gesellschaft und damit für uns
alle lebensnotwendig und wir wollen auch
weiterhin dass hier bei uns Lebensmittel
produziert werden und die Betriebe in
Putins Krieg mit all seinen Folgen
bestehen können deshalb haben wir neben
der angesprochenen Berücksichtigung bei
der energiepreispauschale auch ein
Hilfspaket speziell für diesen Arbeits-
und energieintensiven Bereich aufgelegt
zum einen gibt es die anpassungsbeihilfe
diese wird unbürokratisch und direkt an
die Betriebe ausgezahlt zum anderen gibt
es das kleinbeihilfeprogramm hier ist
zwar eine Antragstellung notwendig aber
die Abwicklung läuft über die
Bundesanstalt für Landwirtschaft und
Ernährung und die hat die Betriebe die
berechtigt sind bereits schon
angeschrieben und die Antragstellung ist
bis zum 31 Oktober möglich die
Unterstützung der Unternehmen und
Beschäftigten in diesem Bereich ist
folglich
systemrelevant das hat nicht zuletzt
auch die Bundesnetzagentur festgelegt
indem sie diese Betriebe bei einer
möglichen gasmangelage geschützt hat und
keine Einschränkung und diese Betriebe
auch keine Einschränkungen fürchten
müssen uns ist klar dass die
Herausforderung nicht nur putinskrieg
ist mehr Fortschritt Wagen das ist unser
Ziel und das gilt auch für die land- und
Forstwirtschaft um den Gartenbau wir
stehen an ihrer Seite die Ampel hat die
Menschen im Blick
Isabel Macken sind Geist letzte
Rednerinnen und jetzt kommen wir zur
Abstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf zur
energiepreispauschale für Rentnerinnen
und Rentner und Versorgungsempfänger des
Bundes Aussprache und wir kommen zur
Abstimmung und ich bitte um
Aufmerksamkeit weil es ja jetzt ein
wenig
konkreter wird wir kommen zur Abstimmung
über den von den Fraktionen SPD bündeln
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur Zahlung
einer energiepreispauschale an Renten
und versorgungsbeziehende und zur
Erweiterung des
übergangsbereichs der Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales empfiehlt unter
Buchstabe a seiner Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache 40/95 den Gesetzentwurf
der Regierungskoalition auf Drucksache
39 38 anzunehmen die Fraktionen der
cdu/csu und AFD haben jeweils beantragt
über den Gesetzentwurf getrennt
abzustimmen und zwar zum einen über
Artikel 3 Nummer 2 das Gesetzentwurfs
Änderung des § 20 Absatz 2 Absatz 2a
Satz 1 und Satz 6 des 4 Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch und zum anderen über
den Gesetzentwurf im übrigen
ich rufe zunächst auf Artikel 3 Nummer 2
ich bitte nun diejenigen die Artikel 3
Nummer 2 des Gesetzentwurfs zustimmen
wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen die Linke cdu/csu AFD
Artikel 3 Nummer 2 ist damit angenommen
ich rufe nun auf die übrigen Teile des
Gesetzentwurfs ich bitte diejenigen die
den übrigen Teilen des Gesetzentwurfs
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das ist das gesamte Haus
Enthaltungen gegen Stimmen sehe ich
keine die übrigen Teile des
Gesetzentwurfs sind damit angenommen
alle Teile des Gesetzentwurfs sind damit
in zweiter Beratung angenommen kommen
wir nun zur dritten Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
das ist DIE LINKE die
ampelfraktion und die CDU CSU wer stimmt
dagegen
wer enthält sich
die afd-fraktion der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit angenommen ja vielleicht noch mal
zur Erläuterung
es war ja in der Debatte schon deutlich
geworden dass es zwar eine sehr große
breite Unterstützung für das Vorhaben
gibt die energiepreispauschale von 300
Euro nachträglich eben auch für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner jetzt auf dem
Weg zu bringen und auszuzahlen aber
gerade bei dem Bestandteil des Gesetzes
wo es um die Anhebung der
verdienstobergrenze bei diesen
sogenannten Midijobs gegen da ist ja in
der Debatte deutlich geworden dass nicht
nur bei der Anhörung die Expertin da
ihre Zweifel hatten sondern es ist ja
auch kritisiert worden beispielsweise
von der Linken das ist
teilzeitfälle und manifestieren würde
sozusagen und die niedrigste und
Teilzeitbereich verfestigen würde auch
die Union hatte hier kritisiert und
deswegen ist ein Teil dieses
Gesetzentwurfs zumindest versucht worden
die Trend aufzurufen da gab es also
nicht die ganze Zustimmung des Hauses
aber wie gesagt
alle zugestimmt dann bei Enthaltung der
AFD in der dritten Lesung das heißt die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner nicht
überraschend gekommen dann jetzt
ausbezahlt das soll ja noch
funktionieren bis 15 Dezember hat
zumindest der Sprecher der Deutschen
Rentenversicherung jüngst noch einmal
betont